we'll joining me now from lamington spa
live is the Lloyd's pharmacy chief
executive Toby Anderson Toby welcome to
you are you seeing shortages of any
medicines right now no we're not seeing
any shortages we are extremely busy
though and it's a very stressful
situation for our wonderful teams and
I'd like to thank those amazing teams to
be last week alone we've served safely
more than 2 million people across all of
that Lloyds pharmacies which is pretty
incredible because we managed to open
every pharmacy this week despite having
sickness in our own workforce and across
the communities there are big big thanks
to both Lloyd's pharmacy but all
community pharmacies out there that are
really on the front line of helping the
government to fight this terrible virus
and I wanted to thank some of that
customers too I mean we've had to make
some operational changes and I really
appreciate their patients particularly
those customers who have given our team
some appreciation there's a mom in the
West Midlands near here that yes son
just came out of the liver transplant 20
days ago and this for the medication we
were able to help her but I have to also
say unfortunately some of our frontline
workers have experienced some abuse
unacceptable abuse as well and just
yesterday I had to temporarily close six
pharmacies there's a violent and abusive
behavior and I want to appeal to
everybody we're all in this fight for
Kobe together and I really like to
appeal please show the respect that the
pharmacy teams need so they can safely
dispense medication for you and for your
loved ones and every day they're putting
themselves at risk day after day helping
people in the community particularly
where GP surgeries are closed and
self-isolation is very high they are
facing significant pressures and we are
having record volumes of prescriptions
we are coping and we are serving you but
our teams are pretty exhausted I'm very
sorry to hear that Toby I mean have you
had to put security guards in places
some pharmacies we haven't our teams are
doing that we are diverting all of our
resources everything we've got keeping
up
pharmacys up and running all of our
clinical staff are in the field
we've redeployed over 300 people from
support centers we've had an amazing
response from our friends and family 250
people have gone into warehouses to
ensure the flow of medicine to hospitals
and pharmacies and as you mentioned
we've got an appeared out there for
another 1,500 people to come and help us
the challenge though is there's only a
certain amount of clinical people out
there with the skills that are required
and so we've got to put in place these
protective measures to look after our
frontline health care workers and that
has been 14 led us to put in place the
queuing system social distancing we're
putting up screens on the cashiers and
providing our employees with protective
equipment and masks all right Toby
Anderson gotta leave it there I'm afraid
thanks very much for joining me good to
see him